when you're trying to take ownership of
a mistake made by a fellow team member
what do you do if the team leader asked
for a step by step step by step
breakdown of events I've said it was our
mistake and not to n-not made excuses
but a step by step breakdown would
expose the fact that he alone was
responsible for the error hmm
interesting so he basically that's
interesting it is wait wait so he's been
saying okay it's our mistake right I
don't want to individualize this guy or
so you know make him stand out or
whatever it's our mistake and we're
gonna fix it kind of thing and he's like
no I want to step by step by step step
by step is gonna reveal ready the solo
actually bills fault and now what I did
I tried so hard to take ownership but
here it was actually bill that was all
Jack yeah actually not my it's exactly
not my fault is what we're saying it's
it's the truth right you get that right
yeah I guess check it out who's
responsible when you're taking ownership
of something when you're taking extreme
ownership of something whose fault is it
yeah mine yeah sure does that include
when someone else on your team makes a
mistake yes but how can that be good
it's your team so let me ask you these
questions here's what I'd be thinking
the teammate was in error why why did
the teammate make a mistake
why didn't the teammate have backup why
didn't the rest of the members of the
team why didn't I actually go through
with him and make sure that he knew how
to do that procedure properly he's part
of my team we're responsible for this
taking place I knew he was a little bit
shaky and I didn't do anything to fix it
that's why it's our fault it's not our
fault because we say oh it's our fault
but it's really bill that's not that's
not what we're talking about the point
is the point is to actually own it so if
my coworker fails
I'm literally saying to myself what
mistake did I make that my coworker
dropped the ball what mistake did I make
my coworker dropped the ball what
mistake did I make
did I not show it to him
did I not ask him if he knew how to do
it did I not ask him if he needed some
help did I not confirm that he knew the
procedures correctly all those things
are my fault did I not do a good job of
identifying that bills a little bit slow
on the uptake and therefore he needs a
little extra preparation for this and
now now think about this what can I do
once I make those mistakes okay we're
gonna do fix them and now think about
this from a leadership perspective you
go down and you say hey guys you guys
messed up this thing why did it happen
now think about the team wherever it
goes well you know it's our fault
mostly bill right and I'll tell you when
I when when when I look at a platoon and
bill made a mistake I don't look at bill
a good leader doesn't just look at bill
a good leadership looks at everyone on
the team especially certainly the
leadership but I think this guy's
talking about from a peer but it doesn't
matter from a peer perspective if
there's a mistake that happens we are
truly responsible and then from a
leadership perspective when I go down to
the team and I say hey guys what
happened and they said well it was our
fault but this is what Bill did I okay
so you just drop a dime on bill I'm not
gonna say okay so it's all bills fault
cool I'll tell you what whereas if you
say hey listen boss is what happened
here's the procedures we went I don't
think we did a good job a briefing bill
cuz here's what bill did he did step
three instead of step four my fault we
went through twice but why should have
gone through it a couple more times and
confirmed he knew what was going on it's
not gonna happen again we got this which
guy you want to work for which guy do
you which which team do you want you
want the team where people are taking
ownership of the problem not blaming
bill ownership is not just saying we own
it ownership is actually owning it and
that's what makes it so powerful what
makes it so powerful is if you actually
own it then you actually look at bill
beforehand and you go look at our team
do we have any weaknesses yeah we did we
got bill and bill doesn't bill can't get
this part of the procedure done right
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
put bill into this other position that's
an easier part of the procedure we're to
make sure he knows how to do that
meanwhile we're
Mike and Mike is gonna go down here and
he nails this procedure and and he's
gonna spend by the way an extra 15
minutes a day during lunch he's gonna
get bill trained up so bill can
eventually that's the kind of thing you
do on a team mmm yeah you made it pretty
clear with juice which is kinda because
it's not that easy to understand or it
wasn't for me anyway I mean it would put
it this way it was it was very valuable
one I did understand this about extreme
ownership I said this before too by the
way so there's there's essentially two
parts of it that make it extreme
ownership well actually there's three
there's the dichotomy but aside from the
dichotomy this is what it is you take
responsibility and then you say what
you're gonna do to fix the problem and
then actually there's a third part which
is you implement the solution yes yes
okay you identify it you own the problem
you identify a solution for the problem
and then you implement the solution yes
that's what you do yeah so a lot of
times it'll be especially in the
beginning like I would just as far as me
just kind of casually trying to
understand it I would focus so much on
taking responsibility you know it's my
fault you know kind of thing it's like
well the taking responsibility I mean is
arguably more important than saying that
it's your fault kind of thing it's
essentially you're taking responsibility
of the solution as well yeah so if not
you cuz in a way in a lot of practical
cases you don't even have to identify
whose fault it is
if you take responsibility of the
solution like if I'm okay here so if
there's a football team right that's
like the epitome of team not the epitome
but what a good example of teamwork
never mind the SEAL Teams or whatever
but well football is please it'll be
more simple because it's it so let's say
okay we got a pass or whatever and boom
the play the play starts and a guy gets
through the front line let's say the
guard missed a block obvious right he
missed it maybe he looked one way and he
was supposed to look this way he was
supposed to not pull and he tried to
pull something he just made a mistake he
just made a mistake he's not in company
just made a mistake whose fault is it
guards fault okay but if the quarterback
is gonna take extreme ownership he's
gonna be like hey no party hey this
happened you know next time we're I'm
gonna remind them how
this play that play you know this read
46 don't curve twist or whatever you
like you don't pull and he probably be
like on man I know I know don't don't
stall them just like hey you don't know
ain't no problem but we're just not
gonna do that anymore and then next time
I call that play I'll be like you're
good right I'm gonna check with them I
didn't check with him that first time
you made a mistake my check with him he
won't make that mistake again I liked
you when we were now we can whenever
driving need me you know yeah it's kind
of one of those things the quarterback
took responsibility for solving the
problem or so then he was like okay Lutz
that was my fault that making a big deal
out of it being his fault no in his head
it is you know it's like okay this is my
fault I should you know I should make
sure things are clear kind of thing like
the weather too you know your weather
yeah well what bothers me the most about
this question is I feel like I feel like
I don't do a good job of explaining this
because what bums me out is someone
whoever wrote this question and it's a
good question I get the question I get
scared that the person that's listening
to the question goes no chuckle doesn't
quite get it he doesn't quite get the
fact that there was this one guy who was
part of the team who made this mistake
and no one you know we just we can't
hold his hand every time like that's
it's not my fault it's not our team's
fault when bill drop completely drops
the ball that's not my fault it's not
any one of the team's fault and my point
is is exactly what you are saying echo
yes it is and if you look at it when
bill makes the mistake himself he's
alone in a room and he's supposed to you
know he's supposed to put part a on top
a Part B and bolt them together that's
his part of the job he's alone in a room
doing that and he doesn't do it right
that's 100% his fault the answer is no
actually who's in charge of training him
who's in charge of checking who not even
in charge of who's responsible we are a
team that means we work together
that means we confirm that we know how
to do our individual parts of the job
that means we check in
say hey bill are you good hey bill let
me check your first three that you do to
make sure you understand what's
happening we do this together as a team
and it makes me feel like a failure that
people have a hard time understanding
this and and I know it's it can be a
stretch it can be a stretch and you know
I give all those examples
hey the machine gunner shoots in the
wrong direction whose fault is that it's
not the machine the machine gunner
literally pointed the machine gun in the
wrong direction pulled the trigger and
shot in the wrong direction whose fault
is it
it's the squad leaders it's the fireteam
leaders it's the platoon leaders because
they didn't make sure that he understood
his field of fire make sure he
understood how to operate his weapon and
by the way there's a chance that the
reason that bill screwed this up and
bill is incapable of putting these parts
together correctly and if that is the
situation guess what is a responsibility
of the team to either get him trained up
to where he can't do it or to tell the
leadership that this guy cannot he's
incapable of doing the job and therefore
he needs to not be here mm-hmm that's
what ownership is that's what extreme
ownership is I think I know what it is
but what what makes it confusing or
sometimes kind of kind of slippery like
to grasp you know because it depends on
who you ask
so a lot of times the thing is when when
it's the machine gunners fault the thing
is if I'm if I'm not even a human being
I'm just the disembodied brain okay it's
the machine other's fault and the
leaders fault and that it's everyone's
fault if I'm you know but but if you ask
the individual person because he has
some machine gunner Hey okay jockle
you're the machine gunner you shot in
the wrong direction and I ask you whose
fault is that what are you gonna say now
leaders well well if your fault well let
me let me tell you right now there are
plenty of people and definitely plenty
of machine gunners that when they shoot
that weapon in the wrong direction you
know what they say I didn't get a clear
brief from what the fields of fire were
no one to I didn't see the markers for
what the range limits were I didn't know
where the other blue forces were no one
told me so they're looking at it like it
actually isn't their fault now you get
some good machine and actually guess
what when you have a guy that's a
machine gunner that says what wasn't my
fault it was my leaders fault you know
what the leader says you know the leader
says
you're a bad leader the the leader in
this team the leader in this team you
know what he says no it was the machine
gunner swap yeah that's right now guess
whose fault it was it was no one's fault
yeah the machine gunner think is the
boss's fault the boss thinks it was a
machine gunners fault now who's gonna
fix the problem the answer is no one no
yeah when you get a good team the
machine gunner goes my fault I should
have paid better attention that leaders
is my fault
and now you have everyone taking
ownership of the problems yes yeah and
that way it's supposed to be but that's
my point and that's why it makes it's
never mind your disembodied brain that's
making decisions over here this is why
it's hard for people to understand
that's why sometimes and I'm with them
I'm like I was there it's kind of like
it's kind like you sure I'm trickin
extreme ownership you know the typical
I'm taking extreme ownership but we also
build for folk but the reason that it is
so hard because if I ask ok we have
three guys one of those guys is a
machine gunner the other guy's a leader
the other guy is just another team
member he's you know he's dead the
sniper something if I say hey this
machine that I shot in the wrong
direction individual meetings they all
take extreme ownership all of them are
down there in the game yeah all of them
I asked you machine gunner whose fault
is that what's he gonna say took my
fault ok next guy who's faulted that
fireteam leader my fault I shouldn't
tell them and their squad leader my
fault I should have told them right yes
so it the read now go back to the
disembodied brain it's kind of like wait
wait wait wait so it's like he did it
it's hard to grasp like that one guy it
is his fault thing is not just his fault
apparently because everyone said it's
their fault right so he was obviously
his fault but wait it's everyone's fault
kind of thing so when you're the guy and
you're saying okay his fault in that
little thing creeps in your brain that's
like yeah wait it is his fault yeah you
know any and you're wrong yeah yeah yeah
and you're wrong and I need to do a
better job of explaining to Pete that to
people because I see questions like this
on a fairly regular basis which is but
hey really you know there's okay I get
ownership but really yeah that's what I
mean it's the but really that you need
to check yourself on yeah because the
reality is you're responsible
yeah you wait but if I'm responsible
what about the machine he just said he's
responsible oisin gunner you're well I
know but the machine gunner said seemed
saying though I think that's the feeling
that that Jeff you like creep in yeah
and that's gonna be a problem
Yeah right you ever seen office space so
really when you think about okay what's
the big thing I don't see as the movie
remember yes you know yes you okay let
me let me remind you kay so in the
beginning they were like hey Peter we're
putting cover sheets on the TPS reports
from now on or we've been doing that you
did you forgot to do that
right so first Lumbergh comes his boss
force Lumbergh comes is like yeah you
know saying hey let me he didn't do it
in a dick way annoying for sure but he
said hey this is basically a reminder
did you get that memo we're putting
cover sheets on the TPS reports you sir
I just forgot it was a one time thing no
problem it's like cool all you know so
if you just do that do that that'd be
cool and he's like cool no problem so
I'll even give you another copy of that
memo he almost like overdid it not
almost he did overdo it so he left and
then the other boss boom who's like one
level down he came same deal
hey we're putting did you get that memo
TPS reports cover sheets now Poppa blah
he's like I got the memo I forgot one
time thing is like yeah I'm just all
those bosses were do doing just making
sure the problem got solved right doing
everything in their power even his
father his friends were like hey what's
up I heard you guys you're having
problems with your TPS so they were just
taking extreme ownership taking
ownership of the problem trying to solve
it but we give them crap about it who
doing it for the movie in a movie
somewhere yeah yeah because they're
trying to make it funny dude yeah I know
I know but that's kind of chronic but
yeah I know but it's ironic okay it is
you know so I'm not even mad at Lemberg
for that this thing